made into electronic systems throughout
the UK there appear to be the result of
a ransomware attack
GCHQ the nca are doing all they can the
UK is under attack its last line of
defense these 42 mostly men tapping away
at keyboards it's not quite James Bond
security experts say the threat is real
and the UK is under resourced GCHQ
Britain's highly secretive and
controversial spy agency a part of an
alliance with big business and the
police to recruit the best computer
minds after a year of competition and
the final game is being held here in
Winston Churchill's World War 2 bunker
under the streets of London Rob Patridge
works for UK telco BT they handle every
financial transaction in the country and
one of the event sponsors in the UK with
face where the big problem is a cyber
security skills gap cyber skills gap and
you know it's difficult sometimes
impossible to find the right people for
the contestants this is serious business
GCHQ agents who we can't show on camera
sit over their shoulder marking their
skills and judging their leadership then
the team has to go before an
intimidating panel the real government
and industry experts
the winner was nineteen year old will
Shackleton he studies at Cambridge
University has just got a job at
Facebook this is really really good fun
for me and also ultimately it can lead
to a job in future in cybersecurity the
new heroic face of a very 21st century
threat